literally
it also when it comes to productivity
and focus and fulfillment it's not when
you get up it's how you get up
and there's all this crazy research like
i'm not some sort of like psycho about
the alarm clock or the snooze button i
personally love sleeping in but i also
know that as somebody that's struggled
with anxiety for
three decades
lying in bed in the morning or at night
is the worst place i can be absolutely
that is where the anxiety can pin you
down like a gravity blanket and so
understanding that the habit of hitting
the snooze button has a detrimental
impact on your productivity all day
because what happens is when you wake up
your brain is typically ready to wake up
when you drift back to sleep after
hitting the snooze button your brain
drifts back into a sleep cycle which
based on research takes about 75 minutes
to complete when the alarm goes off nine
minutes later your brain is now trapped
in a sleep cycle and researchers say it
takes you about four hours to snap out
of what they call sleep inertia
that impacts your productivity all day
long and so you're complaining that i
didn't get enough sleep and you feel
groggy
no you actually got plenty of sleep
you screwed yourself over by hitting the
snooze button and now your prefrontal
cortex can't snap back into operation
until you're ready to go need motivation
you better watch the top 10 with believe
nation hey it's evan carmichael and i
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
mel robbins and my take on her top 10
rule to success enjoy
rule number two change your view the
reticular activity system the ras for
short um for if you don't know what it
is picture a hair net over your brain
that is a live network and the ras is a
filter and it has a huge job
and it is a filter that blocks out 99
of the world and lets in about you know
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
one percent
and it is always changing
there are only four things tom that get
through the hair net on your head the
sound of your name and you've
experienced this because you've been
walking through a crowd and you're like
did somebody say my name
right
party effects cocktail party effect the
second thing that gets through is any
sort of threat so if you hear a loud
noise and you go like this there are
lots of noises you didn't hear but the
loud one you kind of duck because it's a
threat the third thing is when your
partner is interested in sex with either
you or someone else that's right like
why are you checking that person out
right you know because the brain is
letting that information in the fourth
thing and this is where the
transformation
begins
your brain will let in anything that it
believes is important to you the
zygarnic effect is
the documented fact that when something
is important to you
and i'll explain what that means
your brain opens up a checklist in your
mind
and now your brain once it puts
this item on your checklist it will
store the checklist in your subconscious
it's encoded in your ras
and your mind is now on the alert
to spot things related to it
the way that you make yourself feel like
something is important is your nervous
system goes on alert
while you're thinking about it you're
either super excited about something oh
this is super important or this is the
trauma effect you go on alert and you
have something really bad happen which
is why
things continue to bring it up
throughout the rest of your life so when
you understand that if something's
important to you
your filter will change in real time how
you see the world
you now know how to change your brain to
work for you and looking for hearts is
the way i'm going to prove to you that
this happens i want to give you one
other example because everybody's
experienced this if you've ever gone
shopping for a new car or you've dreamt
about having a new car
what happens immediately when you get
excited about that new car is your mind
goes zion artifact oops okay tom wants
the new bronco that's cool so what do
you see now you see broncos everywhere
now they were always there but your mind
is letting them in because the zygon
artifact
is now made it on a checklist it's
changed the ras
and so i am going to prove to you that
it is
unbelievably cool that you can change
the way that you view the world by
looking for heart-shaped objects so
tomorrow when you wake up you're going
to start your day by high-fiving
yourself in the mirror i want you to
examine what the resistance about
because you're going to start to then un
be able to unpacked what's holding you
back
then you're going to go out in the world
and just like tell your mind i want to
see a heart today look for a rock look
for a leaf look in your like latte is
there a little shape there is there an
oil stain on the floor
and when you see one
stop and go
i i just
like there's a scavenger hunt i never
would have seen that before thank you
brain
now your brain's like
more hearts
you will start to see hearts everywhere
and when you can start to train your
brain and realize whoa
this is
actually a cool thing this is
high-fiving your mind when you can see
hearts you can now go wait a minute if i
can change what i see based on what i
tell it
maybe if i got serious about not
constantly saying i'm a failure i
wouldn't attach that or see it
everywhere
maybe if i got serious about saying i
can figure anything out
this is happening for a reason instead
of i'm
you say okay i'm going to learn
something with this
it changes the way your brain filters
everything
and this is such an important piece to
the book because we've all had the
experience where you love somebody
deeply
and you see all their incredible
attributes
and all they see is failure or all they
see is the weight that they can't lose
and it doesn't matter what you say it
doesn't matter what kind of pep talk or
support you give them
your loved one still only sees what they
hate about themselves
blame the filter in your brain you have
been bitching about your appearance or
the weight on your scale the fact that
you're a failure for so long your brain
believes it's important to you to see
reasons why this is true
and one of the things i got to say about
this
and everything in the book is the tools
are simple tom but it's super important
to say
just because you change and start
celebrating yourself it's not going to
make the weight disappear suddenly
it doesn't change the number on the
scale overnight what it changes is you
and that changes your ability
to deal with the problems and the issues
you want to change in your life rule
number three show up for yourself
how does your favorite sports team begin
the game
by high-fiving each other to send
yourself out into the game but when
researchers actually studied nba teams
they could predict who's going to be the
most successful teams at the end of the
season and who's going to be at the
bottom of the league based on one
characteristic at the beginning of the
season in the preseason and that is how
many times does the team in the
preseason do fist bumps high fives or
pats on the back
and what they found is it's the teams
that do that the most in the beginning
have the winningest record and the
reason the question is why well the
reason why is these gestures are more
than gestures they are symbols of trust
and partnership
they build momentum and so many of us
are struggling in life with
people-pleasing and guilt and all of
these emotions because we have broken
that partnership with ourselves and this
is a way every morning after brushing
your teeth we're going to stack this
habit put the toothbrush down pick up
your hand look yourself in the mirror
and say how am i going to show up for
that human being today and seal it with
a high five that's it rule number four
interrupt negative patterns let me
explain what happened so this really
interesting concept called
ghosts in the nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated and
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system and so it's why you can have a
pattern from your past
but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out
and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and mom or dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on may 17
1972
but your nervous system remembers what
it's like
so fast forward you're now 51 years old
and
you walk in the house and there's a mess
everywhere and even though you have said
i'm not going to bulldoze and yell at
anybody
my body recognizes the situation
so what do you do you repeat the pattern
you saw
and so what i'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
i was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for share the mic for share the mic
now um trying to create a video and i'm
like doing take after take because i
want to get it right
and my daughter comes waltzing into the
room and was like
how long are you going to be doing this
and i was like
who can't you say that i'm working i
literally like screamed at her and she
looked at me louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how's your
daughter
20.
and i said i i calmly said you're right
i do
when i get interrupted
i
lose control of the response and i'm
working so
hard and the way that you and i'm not
clearly not mastering this yet
but the way that you do it is as you
feel it rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath
you can notice the pattern and you've
got to create a pause between the
emotion rising up and the reaction that
gets automated and for many people the
reaction loss is to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you you hate being
interrupted by anything this is a great
interesting i did like i didn't do i
didn't do the bulldozer i was i was calm
because i wasn't a human being i'm only
mean to human beings um i know like i a
lot of people run away they avoid
conflict they say it's just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict
continues to create a pattern where you
feel invisible and your boundaries are
trumped on that's a pattern and you know
here's the other thing about patterns
running away
and being quiet might have saved you
when you were little
because if you were quiet and out of the
room you didn't get hit you didn't get
yelled at you were out of harm's way
so when you were little it was a genius
pattern because it protected you but the
issue for adults is that again we walk
around with the patterns that we created
when we were eight years old in
different situations and we are in now
and now we are
completely a robot to these patterns
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five flip jealousy jealousy
is one of the most powerful directional
signals on the planet
because you're only jealous of people
that are doing things or have things
that you actually want it's impossible
to be fake jealous whatever you're
jealous of is hitting something deeply
personal
pay attention to it instead of stewing
in it go oh
flip it
that's interesting
i wonder why i'm jealous
what is it about it oh
it's that they're doing it consistently
it's that they've built a team it's that
they've aligned their work together so
that they're spending more time together
huh how could i take those things that
i'm really now really inspired by
and take action and go get them in my
life
because the thing about jealousy is it's
just your inspiration that's blocked
jealousy
is sort of the insecurity
that you have that blocks this
inspiration i guarantee you back to the
uber driver he's jealous of all the
other actors earning oscars
because he's so inspired by the thought
of doing that in his own life
but his insecurity is blocking action
his fear is blocking action so instead
of it being inspiration
it shows up as jealousy and i'm here to
tell you the second you feel jealousy
freaking
stop okay let's unpack that what exactly
is it about it and now if i were
inspired by it because there's enough
success to go around for everybody
if i can use that as a road map to then
go figure out how i might be able to do
that for myself
wow
talk about a game changer and now let's
add in the high five what if every time
i took a little step i celebrated myself
for just doing it now you're building
small wins and momentum in a direction
that's meant for you that's how you
change your life rule number six express
your needs we encourage people to break
boundaries you know they feel like
they're limited
but
you talk about uh your boundaries are
there to serve you so obviously it's a
different type of boundary but
you know yeah so so here's the thing
what boundaries do you need to help
yourself to protect yourself and which
ones do you need to grow past that are
holding you back
i think that the definition with
boundaries that has helped me the most
is understanding the boundaries are for
me they're not for you
and the single biggest mistake that we
make in any relationship particularly
romantic ones but also work related ones
is we do not express what we need any
pattern can be replaced
change isn't personal it just feels
personal change is just about
identifying patterns and replacing them
with new ones that's it
and it'll take a little while because
they're encoded in your nervous system
and your default is to just do it
yourself
um but you have to you cannot as a rule
punish other people for you didn't
communicate right so i'll give you the
perfect example so chris and i have been
married for 24 years and when i was
before the talk show and i made my
living mostly by uh you know doing 100
speeches a year
i would be on the road 150 days a year
and
when i would come home there was always
something
that pissed me off
like what like ah the trashes are taken
out the clothes are here or is it
something else oh no i'm way worse than
that are you kidding
i would walk in after being gone for
five or six days
and there
on the island in the kitchen
was a vase
that had dead flowers
the ones that i had bought for myself a
week before and it was as if everybody
in my family had been walking around the
island for six days as if there was some
dead flower sculpture in the middle of
the island and so i would come home
and
first of all the only person that's
really excited to see me is a dog and my
family did sit me down at one point they
said you know you realize when you're
not here we have our own lives so you
don't put your lives on hold while you
know for us and we're not putting our
lives on hold so it's not that we're not
excited to see you but we're not
organizing our whole lives around when
mom comes home right to be like a dog
to be like the dog excited and running
up and jumping in your arms and kissing
you yeah
yeah no no
but that but i think that's cool because
that means
that they're independent and doing their
own thing they've set boundaries
they've set boundaries with me perfect
so
for probably six months i would get
pissy and i would walk in and put my
bags down and i grabbed the flowers and
i demonstratedly how many times has
everyone done this throw them out loudly
like everyone hears you communication
yeah i'm getting my communication just
throwing these dead flowers out
communicate to you that you should buy
me flowers like i'm not saying that but
that's what the body language is right
how dare i have been off i've been in
four cities and then you become a mar
like ugh i'm disgusting when i tell this
story but this is it this is like so
well i see you've got some lovely
flowers behind you that look alive so
that's good to see oh that's nice
so
i do love flowers so finally
i just said to chris you know what would
make me feel
amazing
is if
when i came home
you had
just bought some flowers
just go to the just when you're at the
grocery store doesn't you don't have to
order like i'm saying buy the five
dollar pack of half dead tulips just
something okay
and and then he said why
and this is the most important part of
expressing and look you don't have to
give an explanation if you're trying to
like cut off a toxic person but if you
want to express
boundaries with somebody
because you want them to understand you
more deeply give them the why i said
because it makes me think
that you are excited for me to come home
and that you knew i was coming
because i'm starting to feel forgotten
so underneath the anger louis
wow
was hurt
and feeling like i didn't matter
and so i'll be darned i walk in
and
um
there they are and i literally feel
so seen rule number seven be kind to
yourself
what are the key principles
of how
someone deals with themselves when they
love themselves when they care for
themselves what are those key tenets
those those key values
that we can draw ourselves to and
measure against say am i doing that for
myself i think at the heart of it are
two foundational habits that you need
and one you already mentioned
it's being kind to yourself
it's really that simple and i know you
know the study that they did in the uk
where they looked at every possible
behavior change that you could do in
life
and
whether it was changing in diet
meditation exercise relationship changes
all of it
the one change that has the biggest
impact on fulfillment and happiness is
being kind to yourself and it's the one
change we practice the least because i
don't think we know how yeah i don't how
do yeah how do we be contest well number
one stop the beat down in the mirror and
despite the fact that it might feel
weird or you're going to resist it or
you got a lot of dust oh boy we gotta
wipe it away
oh it's more like mud it's not like dust
jay has dust the rest of us are caked
with mud gotta get some elbow grease in
there uh the high five habit every day
is wiping that away okay that's number
one number two
when you catch yourself
in the what if loop
or the beat down use the five second
rule count backwards five four three two
one interrupt it and start just
interrupting it
because you don't have to listen to it
you can't always control when it pops up
but you can start to create distance
from it meditation obviously helps with
that but in terms of the hand to fist
combat with your own brain
i prefer punch back five four three two
one and then i literally go i'm not
thinking about that
another strategy that you can use as
you're doing the hand-to-hand combat
with your own brain
is
come up with like an avatar for this
negative voice okay and make it really
good like when our son was really
profoundly struggling with anxiety he's
16 now he started to call that worry
wart in his head that was beating him up
oliver and he looked like this big
pimply bully of a kid that was out of
the diary the wimpy kid and he would
literally say when he was nine years old
shut up oliver like you're not invited
to sleep like he would literally talk to
it and it sounds like you're giving your
kid multiple personalities that's not
actually what's happening you're
leveraging objectivity so you separate
yourself from the voice that's talking
to you yes um another thing that you can
do i love this for worrying oh this is a
genius to steal your word uh move when
you catch yourself doing the what ifs
because we know there's two forms of
worrying right there's the type of
worrying that just destroys you that's
destructive worrying where you just
ruminate what if what if what if then
there's the positive form of worrying
which is productive because it it
motivates you to change when you get
stuck in the what if what if what if
interrupt it with this five four three
two one and then go what if it all works
out
what if this turns out to be one of the
hardest things i do but the best
decision i've ever made
what if placing a bet on myself
was the moment my life changed
what if it all works out
because you can't argue with that and it
literally stops
that sort of cycling because worrying is
just a habit that you have it's like a
pathway that you've plowed in your mind
and it's a protection mechanism
you're actually not a procrastinator
you're not a worrier you're just afraid
yeah and by staying in your mind you
think you're safe
and really what you're doing is you're
holding yourself back from living the
life that you're meant to live i love
that that's such a great answer so
that's because i've got a couple of yeah
be kind to yourself and then there's
another one and then the other ones keep
the little promises that you make to
yourself
and there's two simple ways you can
practice this that everybody's gonna
hate
when you set the alarm the night before
i don't believe in having the same
wake-up time every morning
because i think if you have a normal
life
things are constantly changing
and so i think if you were to have one
simple habit which is the night before
you go to bed think about when you need
to wake up to truly support yourself
and then intentionally set your alarm
and if you want to get really
intentional with the science here make
it like a random odd number don't make
it six o'clock make it 617
because there's a purpose behind that
and then when that alarm rings don't
think about it like an obligation
i want you to think about it like it's a
promise
that you're going to practice keeping
and this is where you can use the five
second rule you're just gonna count
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt all of the desire in your mind
and body to stay in bed or to hit the
snooze button or to argue against what
you need to do and you're going to push
through that resistance and take action
and by getting out of bed simply when
you said you would
you are again behavioral activation
therapy you're acting like a person who
keeps their promises rule number eight
take responsibility you talk a lot about
taking responsibility for that
recognizing nobody's coming to save you
something you said in the book it's
something that you've said in interviews
something that i absolutely think is
really powerful
how do we use that why is that important
to recognize
well it's important to recognize because
first of all nobody is coming
i mean if you've been sitting around
waiting for somebody to discover you to
pick you to save you to rescue to give
you your shot it's not happening
like at some point you got to wake up
and realize when you're 18 and you're
out of that house you have to parent
yourself
your life is your responsibility and as
a woman one of the things that i found
to be
extraordinarily transformational is when
i stopped in a very traditional sense
looking to my partner to be responsible
for providing
for me
providing financially providing the
support providing when i realized
wait a minute it starts with me
i have to be
able to figure out how to make myself
happy
that's by the way the secret to a happy
relationship marry somebody who's happy
and work on your own happiness preach
and so when you stop outsourcing
your happiness your validation your
support all of it and you bring it back
in
and you get responsible for it it sounds
scary it's so
liberating because you could do anything
when you're responsible when you're the
driver of your life when you're not
looking out to anybody else to fix it
for you can you ask for help of course
but the buck stops with you
you're the one that has to do the work
you're the one who has to push your own
ass you're the one who has to figure out
what makes you happy you're the one who
has to figure out and become self-aware
about what you need and then you're the
one that has to
find whatever it is the courage or being
humble enough to ask for help
even if it's asking for help
from the biggest ally that you have
which is the person staring back at you
in the mirror every damn morning rule
number nine explore your feelings if you
google word wheel or wheel of emotions
you will find that um if you ask
somebody name as many emotions as you
can most people can name three happy sad
angry
there's literally like 113 of them
from disgusted to hopeless to
and if you if you start with a cor this
thing allows you to start with a core
emotion and go out
because back to the flower example i was
expressing anger
that's not what i was feeling
i was feeling invisible and forgotten
and so the word wheel
is something that we used several times
a week to help people go from the thing
that they are expressing to them
communicating what you're feeling which
is a lot like the work that you wrote
about in your book yeah around wearing
masks getting to the root of the core
emotion you're feeling but not
expressing and rule number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is have fun
oh i can't read my eyes no stop touching
your eyes i can't open my eyes anymore
okay don't open your eyes don't open
your eyes
here
[Music]
i actually have an incredible quote of
yours about dreams you say when it comes
to your dreams you have two choices
pursue them or be haunted by them
it's true you can't forget a dream
you can
something that you want in your life
once you really want it and you give
yourself permission to feel that desire
there's something called the zygarnic
effect
and the zygarnic effect is this thing
that happens in your brain and i also
think it's tied into your heart your
nervous system but it happens in your
brain where
when something is important to you
and you can feel that wave hit you
your mind takes note and goes oh
i'm going to put this on the list in the
file of my mind called this is important
and whenever you are near anything
that's related to what's important to
you
your mind changes the live network and
filter of your brain will change in real
time to try to alert you
to the fact that you're near something
that is important to you and i'm not
making this up this has been proven
in study after study
and
i think that's why your dreams haunt you
you can ignore them you can shove them
down you can tell yourself you don't
want it anymore
but if you've ever wanted something
deeply it doesn't leave you it gets
stored in the subconscious part of your
mind waiting for you to remember that
it's there and to get to work on it if
you've always dreamt of living in an
amazing beach house somewhere
you you will
always think about it
and you'll either pursue it or you're
going to be haunted by it
if you've ever thought about taking your
grandmother's recipe
and
like doing something with that tomato
sauce
you'll either pursue it or it's going to
haunt you
and that's because of how you're
designed as a human being
so you got two choices
you either do something about it
or you're going to live for the rest of
your life with this thing in the back of
your mind that slowly
eats at you that the one person
the one person that is diminishing your
ability
to make these dreams a reality is you
because when you state your dream this
is what happens you state it and then
all of a sudden you're present to how
far away you are from it and when you
see the distance between where you are
and where you want to go the direction
that your dream requires you to walk in
you're going to get present to the gap
and that scares us
that's where fear comes into play and
you start to think of all the reasons
why you don't deserve it you start to
think of all the reasons why you can't
do it all that you have to do
in order to start to pursue your dreams
is take small actions every day that
align
your life in that direction so what does
that mean if you want to play guitar
professionally it means that you start
playing guitar more it means that you
sign up for open mic nights it means
that you go back to class if if that's
something that interests you you see
your dreams will happen
either because of you
or in spite of you
they don't happen because of other
people they happen because of you and
what you do
the second you have the bravery to state
that dream now are you going to create
it or are you going to diminish it in
your mind those of us that are out there
in the world doing big things that one
of the reasons why we're able to do big
things is because we have trained
ourselves to just
push
forward even when things are not the way
that you want them to be going
to keep your cool to
um
roll with the punches even when you
don't have the support that you need and
so uh you know i had something happen
yesterday i was in the middle of giving
a speech so imagine this you're on stage
you are 20 minutes into your speech you
have 40 more minutes to go you have 30
more slides to go to which is what uh
was happening at that point
and all of a sudden my laptop dies
i mean just blank you guys
so i've got an entire audience
i'm through the first third of my speech
i have two thirds of the speech to go
and my speech is a story that has a ton
of of uh videos and and photos in it and
my laptop
died
and what had happened is the av team had
plugged the laptop into a podium that
had no power in it so my laptop was set
up correctly it was plugged in but it
was plugged into something that had
absolutely no power source so over the
course of the hour before the tech check
to when i was on the stage the laptop
has run out of juice and so all of a
sudden
here i am
completely cold laptop i just you know
had this moment where i thought the
first thing in my mind was holy cow
what am i going to do for the next 40
minutes
and i could feel my stomach start to go
crazy
and the butterflies to kick in
and
um
it just
wow um i was i was extremely
panicked for about a second and then i
was like okay use the tools
use the tools
don't don't get nervous get excited
because you can show everybody what
looks like
in front of a live audience to have a
massive technical breakdown and not lose
your cool and so i made a joke about it
the av team ran up i said look you guys
have no power here so take it back there
get it plugged in and i'll talk for two
or three minutes while you get this
thing set up now meanwhile i'm thinking
while i'm talking to a live audience
what if they don't get this set up what
am i going to do how am i going to fill
the 40 minutes when the whole speech is
not only anchored in the story but it's
anchored in
all of these photographs and proof of
people's stories from around the world
and so i'm like don't panic don't panic
use the tools mel and then all of a
sudden the guy shouts out what's your
password you know because my my screen
was locked so then i thought okay we're
going to get this done not a problem it
took about five minutes for things to
get back up and running and it was one
of the longer five minute periods of my
life but i got through it and one of the
reasons why i got through it is because
i've trained myself to roll with the
punches that's what i've trained myself
to do heather
um is held back at work because what
happens is when she has to have a really
difficult conversation when there's
something that she wants to talk to her
boss about when there's a conflict with
one of her colleagues you ever have a
conflict with your colleagues at work
ever feel like you work in a toxic work
environment well this is something that
you need to understand
sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment is about the other people
and sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment or in your life environment
or your friend environment is about
stored memories
in your body from your childhood i know
it's crazy stuff because the saying feel
the fear and do it anyway it's true
because your body feels
situations
that set you
uh
that puts you in a state of being afraid
before your mind catches up and starts
thinking about what you're afraid of and
so one of the key takeaways from take
control and one of the things that i
want to teach you today
is that if you start to tune into your
body
and you start to notice the signals that
your body is sending to you in your
day-to-day life signals like butterflies
in your stomach signals like
feeling a rush of energy up to your neck
signals like your armpits sweating
signals like your hands getting sweaty
signals that your body is stepping and
noticing a situation that reminds it of
your past
learning how to read those signals that
oh my god here goes my body my body is
starting to recognize that this is a
situation that puts me on edge
recognizing those signals first and
slowing the body response down before
your brain starts to go oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
that is a critical skill in taking
control of your life everything we talk
about has to be proven right everything
i love that i don't give you some i've
read in a book or something that i've
read on instagram
the only things that we share are things
that are backed by science that have
been researched that we have seen
working in our own lives that we see
working for our audience and i think
that is critical because let's face it
anybody can put up
a
inspirational quote
you know that they've read from somebody
else anybody can tell you to you know be
positive or do this or put in the work
or hustle or whatever the hell it may be
at the end of the day
it's just talk yeah you have to know how
yeah and i also am you know somebody who
is a little bit cynical
so you know i'm sort of embarrassed that
i'm in self-help on some level because
it sounds stupid right you know i mean i
come from i i mean i i'm older than you
i'm almost 50. self-help had a really
bad name
20 years ago and i also am ivy league
yeah lawyer yeah and
i
um
am an entrepreneur
there's a lot of i mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of fake people out there
for sure i i
renting houses and ferraris and telling
you if you use their click funnel
strategy or whatever strategy that
you'll be rich like they are and yeah
you may and chase the money if it
energizes you but there's a lot of smoke
in there for many of us slowing down is
really scary but that's exactly what you
need to do
and so if you are always in a rush if
you feel like there's urgency in your
life if you move at a pace that makes
you feel panicked or rushed you got a
million things to do and you think that
you're busy but you're not productive
the solution is not doing more it's
doing less it's not speeding up it's
actually slowing down because being busy
doesn't mean you're in control it means
you're being driven by this fear of
slowing down you're being driven by the
fear that when you slow down you're
gonna have to confront where you're at
and you're going to have to start doing
the work and that because that can be
scary
but you take control of your life not by
speeding up everybody
but by slowing down you take control of
your life by removing distraction and
adding in focus you take control of your
life by being honest with yourself about
the things that you're filling your life
with that doesn't matter that makes you
so busy
and that also prevents you from finding
the 15 minutes that you need every day
to really find the courage to focus on
making your life a little bit better or
pushing something forward if you're
somebody who's guilty of being busy and
never having the time to do the thing
that really matters to you that your
heart's calling you to do or you never
have the time to do something to take
care of yourself i want you to find 15
minutes today
and i want you to slow down
whether you've always thought about
meditating and you've never done it
download the comm map
listen to it do one guided meditation go
for a walk for 15 minutes just a quiet
walk without your phone or with your
phone turned off
uh have a cup of tea or cup of top
coffee and read something listen to a
podcast for 15 minutes
take a bath tonight something where you
experience the sensation of slowing down
because again busyness becomes a habit
and when it becomes a habit it becomes
an epidemic and when it becomes an
epidemic
it will rob you of your ability to take
control of your life and at the root
cause of all of this is fear
just the fear of slowing down because
when you slow down and you start to
create priorities and you start to take
control
now you're responsible for what's
happening in your life and you can no
longer rely on just complaining that
you're busy i think the most important
thing i want you to know is whatever it
is that you're dealing with right now
no matter how scary it is no matter how
overwhelming it is
or even if you're just bored with where
your life is or if you're super happy
i want you to know that you always have
the power to change your life because
you have the power to make a decision to
change how you think about something to
change how you treat the people around
you to draw boundaries and to make the
small changes that add up to absolutely
everything you gotta raise your own game
gotta raise your own game and so what is
the game that you play at work you gotta
get out of the head that it's all about
you
the best team members are always
thinking about how to make the team
better the best team members are loyal
to the team the best people to work with
are the ones that are in it together and
so in order for you to get your toxic
colleague to shift behavior you got to
model it and here's the interesting
thing about the research when people are
working with co-workers or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations
it creates what we call psychological
safety which basically just means i feel
safe working with you i know that if i
come to you with feedback you listen i
know that if i tell you how your
behavior is impacting me you'll actually
care i know that if you need help you'll
come to me and i know if i need help i
can come to you that's what
psychological safety means you're a safe
person and hopefully a fun person to
work with
so you've gotta model that that means
you gotta ask for support that means you
to have direct collabor direct
conversations and it means you got to
support your team members too and do you
realize
that when
you work with other people that do this
team members are 35 times more likely
to show visible commitment to your
success and they're 47 more likely when
you model it to work hard to build and
maintain your trust
so don't ever get resigned and thinking
that the way that you behave
won't impact how somebody else is
behaving around you one of the most
important things when you're in a
situation where the truth the facts are
that there is more on your plate than
one human being can effectively handle
on his or her own
there's a really important
moment where you have to surrender
to the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits
but part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that i want things to
go
and so if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going on it's gonna
make it feel even more overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it so i call this and i think sean
anchors the one that came up with this
this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin
on a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are
still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter you
believe that you can handle what's on
your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
health diagnosis
or you're spinning because somebody just
told you they don't want to be in a
relationship with you anymore whatever
it is that you're facing that's making
you feel overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very overwhelming life right now
and still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control often times when you
hit bottom you bounce
and that's where i think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that coveted 19 has done regardless of
whatever devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all
to experience the great pause
and
i read that in a medium article and i
love that idea of a pause because i
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and
when you are forced to pause and get
present and to slow down you are
reminded
of what's actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends
what's important is whether or not you
are taking care of yourself and thinking
positive thoughts versus negative
thoughts the world gave us a gigantic
experiment where we got to practice and
get to continue to practice the most
important skill in the planet which is
emotional resilience the ability to face
hard
and actually be okay
the ability to face the uncertain
and
redirect your attention on things that
you know
that are certain but as is the case in
life you're always going to be growing
and when you hit new chapters in your
life
it's really important to be deliberate
and mindful
about the people that you spend time
with and who you surround yourself with
does that mean you got to ditch your
high school friends absolutely not
but it might mean
that you shouldn't spend as much time
with them
it might mean that you should show up to
those friendships a little bit
differently and maybe they'll go a
little bit deeper and it definitely
means that based on where you are in
your life right now that you should get
more proactive about surrounding
yourself with a group of new friends or
current friends that are up to the same
kind of growth that you are why do you
think that is in human beings that you
know if things are going bad we won't
change
if they're going good we won't change
but it's almost like we need a massive
breakdown near death experience divorce
covid for us to see clearly to start
changing
well there's a really simple answer
patterns
so the thing about all human beings is
that we are pattern
learning machines
and
if you feel
stuck or broken i guarantee you while
you feel that way you're not you have a
pattern of behavior or a pattern of
thinking that is broken
and we
need
to be disrupted
because we love our patterns and even
people that i know like i've heard
pain even when we're in pain we like the
pain is familiar for a lot of people
yeah so a lot of people like you may be
listening to lewis and i talking and you
grew up in a super chaotic household
maybe your parents argued all the time
maybe your dad or mom were in and out
maybe there was a lot of fighting maybe
there was actual abuse i don't know what
was going on but it was chaotic as hell
and so as an adult
you have vowed yourself you are not
going to repeat that pattern
but what ends up happening is because as
a little kid you observed witness
absorbed the pattern of chaos in your
nervous system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do i keep
dating these
why do i why do i go to these bosses
that treat me like crap because you
don't know
what it feels like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in a
state called when's the next shoe gonna
drop right
and so wherever it is in your life that
something is broken there is a pattern
that you don't see yet that is making
you continue to stay in a broken
situation it's all that thinking that
overthinking that thinking too big
thinking big is about dreams thinking
big is about goals thinking big is about
your heart and your soul and figuring
out what you want then once you do that
and you think big and you see where
you're headed
boom you got to come back and you've got
to go brick by brick to make that vision
stick you've got to go brick by brick to
make the action stick you've got to go
brick by brick to lay that pathway
forward and to keep going and let me
tell you something i don't care how busy
you are i don't care how tired you are i
don't care how much there is to do to
make this big dream forward you have
time to lay one brick a day you really
do you really do and this is the secret
everybody this is the secret to
everything it's to understanding that
there is no timeline to getting your
dreams done
all there is to do is to allow your
heart and soul to dream big
to see the path forward and then to pull
yourself into the moment every day and
have the discipline to be deliberate to
lay one brick on that path that's it and
to keep reminding yourself that
everything that you're learning on the
way is you lie bricks down and you move
forward a little at a time
is helping you build the path and there
will be times that you start to lay
bricks in this direction and you realize
whoa wait a minute i'm going over here
and my dream is over there i guess i
better lay bricks over here and head
back in the direction then you're gonna
go this way that's great because
everything that you learned over here
is going to be exactly what you needed
in order to be
doing what your big dream is having a
breakdown is one of the biggest things
on the planet because what you get is
you get a break from your own
and you can look
objectively at where you are and for the
first time
look ahead and say well what do i want
to go create and nine times out of ten
if you're discouraged right now if
you've got financial devastation if
you've if you're facing something that
is making this moment in time as hard
for you as life was for lewis and i in
2008 during the last recession
i beg you
ask yourself honestly if what you had is
actually what you wanted
the thing that you just lost that that
job that you bitched about all the time
a relationship that was bad to you yeah
yes or the friends you can't hang out
with because it's convenient and you
can't you're in court like actually ask
yourself if this is what you wanted or
were you just used to it
um
being used to something
louis i think is the biggest reason why
people don't change
i asked my mother i love my mother i
love my parents i've been married 51
years
which is a feat because they were my mom
was a teen mom but
uh i asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development seminar with me
what'd you say
are you [ __ ] kidding me
why would i want to change at my age
i might discover i hate my life
wow
i was like okay i'm just going to leave
that right there
right
and i always talk about how you have the
power in your life always i know that
you may have your feelings hurt i know
you may be angry or upset or frustrated
i certainly feel those things all the
time in my life but i want you to
understand that no matter what's going
on you always have the power because you
can choose what you think and what you
do next
you may not be able to control the way
that somebody treated you you may not be
able to control
uh the number of promotions that have
passed you by you may not be able to
control whether or not your boss is a
jerk face or not to you but you can
choose how you respond to these things
and that's where your power is and this
is a very important first piece of
advice by the way is that a lot of times
we start to feel the weight of the
overwhelm but we don't get out of our
heads and if you spend too much time
thinking about all the stuff that's
going on and you don't go through the
process of breaking it down and figuring
out what actually is important to you
and prioritizing what you're going to do
about it you're just going to continue
to feel heavier and heavier and heavier
it's more and more sunk i mean it's it's
a very very difficult thing to feel why
don't you like the size you are
is it
okay
because i don't believe in losing weight
to be skinny
i believe in
getting healthy because of how it makes
you feel yeah so if you love the size
that you are and it's healthy you should
stay the size that you are
but
if you look in the mirror
and seeing your body the size that it is
gives you evidence to say i'm a piece of
or i'm unworthy what do you say to
yourself when you see yourself in the
mirror
all of those things tell me what is it
let's get it out of your head
and let's bring it to the light because
you know you feel comfortable saying
this to yourself
when you're alone don't you
i want you to say it out loud because
it's it's not
okay to say this stuff to yourself what
do you say to yourself that we're not
going to say anymore i'm disgusting i'm
disgusting what else
the way i look i hate the way that i
look i hate it i hate the way that i
feel okay what do you want what do you
deserve
to feel good when they walk down the
street yes
yes you do see i think at the heart of
this
i think at the heart of this is a belief
that you don't deserve
to feel that way
so who taught you to feel that that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it holly
maybe
that's usually when it happens
so what i want you to do
is i want you to leave here and what
you're going to go to war against is not
your weight you're going to go to war
against the pattern in your head okay
because the longer you invalidate
yourself the less motivated you're going
to be to change yeah because you're
beating yourself down so we got to start
with not fixing you
you're not broken
you're perfect how you are holly you are
i know you don't feel that way but i
feel that way yeah
it's the pattern up here
that's broken yeah so we just want you
to have a zero tolerance policy for this
like i'm not worth it i don't deserve it
i'm a piece of this um all that no five
four three two one it's like an axe
you got that
and then you're going to come up what
can we say instead i can do this i do
that i can do this but more important i
think it needs to be more heart-centered
i deserve
to feel good yeah i deserve
to have what i want
watch me go get it first of all you're
not in a race so there's no catching up
and i want you to stop saying you need
to catch up with everybody right now
whether you're facing this issue at work
because you haven't been promoted or
you're facing this issue because you're
the only one of your girlfriends who's
not engaged or married or pregnant or a
mom yet or if you're facing this issue
because you feel like you look around
and you're comparing your life to
somebody else's stop that stop that stop
that stop that it is
one of the most horrible things that you
can do because it's very demotivating
because what you're doing is you're
making yourself wrong for where you are
and that's not going to make you
motivated what i want you to do is see
the gap and recognize that if you're
jealous it's because you want that thing
that's why my own mind because it's not
something i'm used to yet is making up
stories to cling to the old way of life
this is a moment in time everyone please
this is the greatest gift
the greatest gift is this moment of
pause where you get in touch with what
you actually want and if you don't have
the skills for crying out loud look
around and take an online course because
if you need skills
to prepare yourself for the thing that
you want get them right now
when you hit a moment in your life or
your work or your family where you feel
very overwhelmed
one of the most important things to not
do
is to not speed up
i tend to be the kind of person that
when i get overwhelmed or i feel the
weight of a world on my shoulders or i
feel stuck i tend to start running into
a brick roll head first at about 50
miles an hour
that is exactly what you should not do
you should slow down
you should slow down and you should
assess where you are and you should
bring that realistic optimism
to doing some problem solving
and some planning
and some decluttering
in your very busy life in four three
four main categories okay
it's so important that you
slow down and realize that part of the
overwhelm is coming from the fact that
you are too busy
there is too much on your plate
there's probably a lot on your plate
that's the wrong things there are
probably things that you're thinking
about that are not important and that's
why once you slow down you also start to
think about being a realistic optimist
you also need to declutter and that's
where your friend mel robbins comes in
setting a quitting cut time isn't
something that i invented it's something
i stole from a professor at caltech
and the the
setting acquitting time habit is so
important it leverages something called
parkinson's law parkinson's law is a
phenomenon around time that basically
says this
anything that you have to get done you
will get done in the amount of time that
you give to it so let me just ask you
this if you think about your to-do list
if you have 10 hours today to work on it
how long is it going to take you to get
through it 10 hours
if you have 10 minutes to get through
the to-do list that you have how long is
it going to take you 10 minutes because
the things you need to do expand or
contract according to how much time you
have to give to it and so what i want
you to do right now because part of your
problem with your routine is you don't
have one you allow work to bleed into
your evening you allow work to just
constantly show up whenever the email
arrives and you're the one that has to
hit
reset on your routine so that you don't
allow your work to do that when a
manager or a boss
defines norms
the team is 73 times more likely to work
hard to keep them and here's the kicker
they're
125 times more likely to address the
situation if there's somebody on the
team who is not operating within the
norms
you know i it's it's so obvious
i mean think about it if somebody were
to walk in
to work
and uh put their feet up on the desk and
turn on porn
and be sitting at their desk watching
porn would that be the norm
for your workplace i don't think so
unless you're working for playboy or
you're working in the porn industry
that would be so out of the norm that
everybody would address it immediately
period full stop
and what i want you to understand is
that when you take responsibility for
how you're acting on the team and you're
collaborative and you're supportive and
you're putting the team first and you're
modeling that behavior and when you also
bring the courage and you dare as brene
brown says to be brave enough to have
honest conversations with your
colleagues about what's acceptable and
what's not based on how things are
impacting you
you personally shift the culture in a
positive direction now here's a trick
about gratitude writing down what you're
grateful for
doesn't work unless you do it this way
because if you if i ask you what you're
grateful for everybody says the same
thing i'm grateful to be alive i'm
grateful for my health and i'm grateful
for my family and that's so generic
that you're not retraining your brain
right you've got to add in the because
i'm grateful for x because
and the added detail will make you
change up what you say and it will also
train your mind in a way that's more
detailed so it actually has a lasting
impact on the way that you view the
world just because you identify
and for me as a kid for whatever reason
i have my own version of feeling
invisible and feeling like i'm not good
enough and so my way of coping both with
my anxiety and being a survivor of
sexual abuse
and
um
and wanting love which we all need is i
was like an overachiever
and so i'm the kind of person that's
super busy and a go-getter because it
got me attention
and if i was the one that was super busy
and achieving i not only got praise but
it also insulates you
from
other people not picking you
because you're the one in a leadership
role doing the picking right and so
there's a part of me at the age of 51
that is realizing
that you know this these feelings of
feeling unworthy
and
this hyper drive
to try to achieve
it's all coming
from a place of feeling inadequate or
like what i'm doing is not enough and so
that's at 50
having a talk show having a best-selling
book having the audible originals having
the platform everywhere having the
impact is still don't feel being the
most booked female speaker in the world
like you still don't feel so
stupid it's annoying and human beings
are annoying we are stuck with this
wiring like if you think about it like
all of the crap you believe is probably
a hangover from age zero to ten
that as adults we walk around thinking
the same stuff we thought as kids
and i
can't stand that i feel that way
but knowing it it allows me to catch it
before it has me
before it stops me from
having an event or writing that next
book or taking a risk here's the thing
about morning routines i think morning
routine envy is a real thing
and
i do believe that a lot of people lie
about their morning routines
i think lying about your morning routine
is a real thing i think pretending you
have the perfect morning routine is a
real thing
um
i'm
i'm about when i'm home i'm almost 80 in
my morning routine i get it done
because it's super simple right so i
mean i think i need a simple one yes
and when i'm traveling
i almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses and so
i think the key to
having a morning routine and morning
routines are critical
because how you start your day
has a
massive
proven impact on how your day turns out
there's one piece of research that i
think is really profound and this comes
from sean anchor i talked about this
yesterday but i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you um this too susie
if you consume three minutes just three
minutes of negative news
of negative television
of negative emails maybe stressful
emails from work or stressful texts from
friends
you have more than a 50
chance eight hours later to say you had
a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind
it literally sets your mind up to be on
the lookout for things going wrong
and so the reason why a morning routine
is is actually so important is because
number one
it determines what your priority for the
day is
and we also know based on research that
your mood in the morning it impacts your
productivity all day long everything
that i have done since since we launched
a five second rulebook was in reaction
to things that were coming to me
so i never sat out and said
hey the five second rule audiobook has
been a complete uh like record breaker
we clearly have an audio audience let's
go pitch audible bottle came to me which
is fantastic
um i never i always dreamt about having
a talk show but i wasn't out pitching
one
sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than half a million
people that have taken our courses
online
was because success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together i
remember i was there interviewing you
for it
oh that was i hated it because what i
discovered is i hate being told what to
do
and so
but that gave me the idea oh we should
do courses ourselves and so this pause
has made me stop and go what do i really
want to do
and
the the truth is i want to go and make
the biggest possible impact that i can
and
i want to collaborate with more people
and
i want to do events
um and i
i don't want to be the ceo i'm a
terrible leader horrible leader
the worst actually
because i'm amazing at coaching i'm
amazing at uh
creating i'm amazing at reacting i'm
terrible at managing people i'm terrible
at managing a project i have add i have
dyslexia
um
i'm a bulldozer when i get anxious
i know we are that's how we
would kill each other if we were
roommates or business partners but
but i think understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that i've decided number
one i'm going to consciously create the
next
chapter and what is that
um well i'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you want to advance you want
to do these things you're talking about
yeah
yes
and i want to i want to collaborate more
with a wider audience of people
and i want to build a brand bigger than
mel robbins yep
i don't want it to just be me i want to
build a
platform based business
that uh reaches more people because
here's the thing that has got that got
me through kind of the loss of the talk
show and the way that i think about
things that i hope helps
um if you're listening kind of
struggling with something
um
i believe and i went into the talk show
saying this to myself because there's a
99
chance based on the history of people
that have tried to have a daytime talk
show that was going to fail
and
i went in there saying
this i'm not doing this because i expect
to have a successful talk show i'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that i have no regrets and i wouldn't
change a thing
but i'm going into this because i know
that there is a skill
a person or an experience i am meant to
have
that will help me
for the next chapter that i can't see
coming one thing that's true about life
is that things are always changing
around you always
whether you are moving into a new season
or in
school
and all of a sudden your kid's school
schedules change or you're moving into a
new season of work and all of a sudden
your work life is changing or you're
moving into a new season of your
marriage or of your health or of
anything
life changes all the time which is why
it's really important to be self-aware
and to make the small changes that help
you
enjoy
and
seize all the opportunities from the
season of life work family relationships
that you're in right now the only thing
that you can do is change yourself for
the better
and hope
that
that means that when you change for the
better
that your friends and the people that
you love and care about are inspired
and encourage change for the better too
and if you have people in your life that
are stuck they probably are all
resigned
they don't believe
that their behavior can change this they
don't believe that their attitude can
change this maybe they're feeling a
little beaten down it's really hard to
acknowledge the fact that your lives are
no longer synced up
but you got to train yourself to look
for the positive
that she still loves you
that she is there for you
and you've got to find new ways to hang
out that's it that's it and here's the
other thing you got to go to work on you
you got to start reaching out and
finding other friends to fill your life
you got to start investing in yourself
in order to pursue the things that are
interesting to you i think the work that
we all have to do
every single one of us whether you
bulldoze
whether you people please
whether you avoid conflict
whether you're impulsive
whether you
yo-yo your decisions
uh
whatever it is that is your pattern
you know you the the constant trashing
yourself
i think the the the journey of your
whole life
is figuring out how to truly
like
and love yourself
if you
are afraid of disappointing people
if you're afraid that you're not good
enough
you may catch that in one area of your
life but as your life gets bigger and as
you change it'll creep in in other areas
and one way that those patterns where
you don't think you deserve it or you
don't think you're good enough or you're
terrified of disappointing people
comes into play is when you start to
expect the worst
and so catch it that's the first step
you can't break your pattern unless you
see it
and then you're gonna replace it and
what i'm gonna start doing is i've got
this little app on my watch you can set
it on your phone
where
every like three hours it reminds me to
breathe and i notice the second that the
alarm goes off i've been holding my
breath
and so you can set a little alarm in
your phone megan's laughing you can set
a little alarm in your phone that just
says savor it's a reminder to take a
minute you can make it say take a minute
take a minute look around
comp your compliment yourself on what's
going right because
expecting the worst is something you
taught yourself to do guess what you can
teach yourself to take a minute
and to savor what's going right and the
more you force yourself to do it the
more it'll become a habit it comes back
to the core message that i always have
for you no matter what's happening
around or to you you hold the power
because you always have the power to
have an honest conversation you always
have the power to discuss how things are
impacting you you always have the power
to make requests and you certainly have
the power to draw boundaries and you
also have the power by the way if the
culture gets worse and worse or you just
are tired of it because it's not
changing to go find a different job
the power is always in you and i think
that's something that's so important to
constantly remind yourself i get that i
don't like where i am but what could i
do to change it
how can i change how i think about this
and i'm telling you right now you know
this the second you start changing how
you think about a situation the
situation changes the second you start
changing how you think about what your
options are you start to see them the
second you stop thinking that you're
stuck or that you're a victim and you
start thinking about how you solve
something you start to see solutions and
so the answer is always in you if you
look at human development we're the only
species that literally can't survive
without another human being taking care
of you and so we are biologically
hard-wired to bond with other people and
that is the ver from the very beginning
of when you come out
bonding with somebody else and making
sure they pay attention to you is your
survival imperative so you are born
needing somebody else and i think what
ends up happening is there's never that
kind of clean
break or pass off between
needing your parents to take care of you
needing your friends approval to fit in
to truly having ownership over giving
yourself what you didn't get giving
yourself what you needed and that's the
piece that i've been doing a lot of
during the the great pause is slowing
down because so much of my busyness
was fueled by uh you know praise me love
me am i doing enough
you know please tell me i'm doing okay
okay i can breathe now i'm okay now
and when i slow down and maybe it's a
function of the anxiety that's when
things get scary because that's when
you've really got to be with yourself
the reason why it's so important to
start with a friend cleanse and i'm sure
a lot of you how many of you heard that
you thought oh my god getting rid of
people oh boy oh boy i'm going to
cleanse these friends
yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships
that are toxic if you have relationships
that cause guilt if you have
relationships that are creating drama in
your life if you have relationships that
are not equitable guess what
that's creating the overwhelm that's
creating unhappiness that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good you have this
behavior pattern where you get angry you
have this behavior pattern where you
snap you have this behavior pattern
where you yell and you get upset and you
make people wrong and you don't mean to
if you
are somebody who's ever said to yourself
i wish i could stop yelling or i wish i
i i i could just snap i could stop
snapping
this video is absolutely unbelievable
okay and the reason why is i explain
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery
a lot of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they are there because when you were
a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologist and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel tense or you start to feel
stressed out guess what happens your
body remembers what it was like when you
were little to feel tense and stressed
out and what were the adults doing
around you when you felt that way
they were snapping they were yelling and
now here you are repeating the pattern
and you don't know why and you feel
guilty
and i'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until i thought holy cow like
i know i don't want to snap at my
husband i know i don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family
why can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern
now all you need to do is basically say
okay i'm going to put a practice in
place that's going to interrupt this
pattern what's the practice well a
really good one is
um
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um
that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun is
you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey
don't take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice
i know
that in this next chapter that i
consciously create i want to have more
fun
i wanna i really wanna love the process
yeah i don't wanna make it so hard on
myself and be gripping everything so
tight
and it's really easy for me to see it in
other people because i know what it
feels like in here i'm working hard to
break the patterns that still hold me
back and the big one that holds me back
is um
bulldozing that's the it's it's it's
literally when i start to feel
any level of tension this is
particularly true in my marriage um i'm
married to a saint thank god chris
robbins meditates every morning it's the
only reason why we've lasted 26 years um
it's how he puts up with me when i feel
my like whatever emotion rise i
immediately raise my voice
it's how i assert power in the
relationship
and i am so committed louis
to
breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
kinder person to be around first of all
stop talking about passion
stop talking about launching a business
okay
when you think about it too big
it will paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where
your bills are getting paid
and you have the luxury of being able to
try to think about what you want to do
in this next chapter
um here's where i want you to start
i want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
i'm speaking at the energetic women's
conference here in indianapolis today
why am i saying energizes here and what
do i talk what am i talking about when i
say energize
when i say energizes you
i'm asking you what is it that you're
curious about
what is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move
of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that
the truth is
passion is just energy
if you're passionate about something it
means you're energized when you do it so
let's reverse engineer this and let's
just
ask yourself a simple question
what are you curious about what
energizes you and if you allow yourself
to explore things that energize you
you my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like
if you're doing something that you're
curious about you're not only gonna
enjoy it you're gonna be really good
you know sometimes when the dream is so
big
the fact that it's so big becomes
paralyzing
because you think about where you are
right now and you think holy cow that
thing that i really want
i don't even like how do you even start
when the dream is so big
so here's what we're going to do today
we're going to shrink it down because
you know me i
am all about simplicity i'm all about
making sure that the advice works for
you because if it doesn't work for you
you're not going to do it and i'm all
about switching how you think about
things huh making this smaller
and making it something that i'm
learning about rather than doing and
launching and
that somehow thinking about it
differently
frees up the ability to get started if i
get you to start doing that and you do
this every day for 10 or 15 minutes
which you absolutely can guess what's
going to happen
you're going to feel momentum you're
going to feel like you're working on it
you're going to meet people that are
interested in it you're going to learn
things that are going to lead to the
next thing that you need to learn and
you will have mastered the art of
getting started and by doing something a
little bit every day you're also going
to master the art of continuing to keep
going and from there it'll snowball i
promise you i promise you you see you're
only ever running against yourself
there's room for all of us there's room
for you to do the same thing there's
room for you to write that book there's
room for you to do those makeup
tutorials there's room for you to launch
that restaurant there's room for you
to start your singing lessons there's
room for you to write that song it is
normal and it is going to happen to you
all the time that you are going to see
people that seem to block out the sun
whenever they make an announcement
because they're that big and that
amazing i don't want you to allow
yourself to shrink when somebody else is
doing something that is
similar to what you want to do refresh
your routine
refresh your routine why is this
important i'll tell you why that's this
is important because there is so much
science that talks about the power of
your morning routine and there's also so
much noise out there about the morning
routine and i don't know about you but
when i read all these articles about the
power of a morning routine i'm typically
reading them by some male influencer who
clearly doesn't have children yet or
some male ceo no no offense to the dudes
but all of the articles out there tend
to be written by guys that have
two and a half hours before work starts
to somehow drink mushroom tea and
meditate and go to yoga and exercise and
drink bulletproof coffee and sit in an
infrared sauna and i don't know what
planet these people live on but they
clearly don't have children or a job
they need to get to at eight o'clock in
the morning and not to make anyone wrong
i'm being realistic i'm being realistic
about the fact that you need a morning
routine but you need one that works for
you
and for where you are in your life in
this season you see i had a morning
routine that used to take me 30 to 40
minutes
last year when i had more time i've had
a morning routine that took an hour when
i had time and the ability to go for a
jog in the morning i'd incorporate that
in the morning routine do you realize
that my morning routine right now
has been responsible for helping me curb
my anxiety it's responsible for why i'm
so successful and i'm able to be
productive my morning routine 10 minutes
long that's it it's 10 minutes long
because that's what works for me in this
season of my life
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there